I remember when I was a kid waiting an
hour for my favorite TV show to come on
which was Sharon Louis and Bram that
felt like eternity but as I've gotten
older everything seems to have sped up
time is going much faster that's
something virtually everyone agrees upon
yeah I feel like I feel like it oh man
so much h es sort of gets faster and
faster but why is this is it just an
illusion or are there good scientific
reasons why time appears to go faster as
we get older well I'm working with the
National Geographic channel's brain
games a show that explores the inner
workings of the human mind through
experiments and interactive games to
test out some theories about why this
actually occurs there is a reasonable
sounding argument that says each year
goes faster because it makes up a
smaller fraction of your entire life
let's say I was only twenty one year is
only one twentieth of my age when I'm 67
one year is 167 of my age this graph
shows one year as a percentage of your
life at each age but when I find weird
about this is if you add up the area
underneath the curve you'll find that
you've already lived half of the total
by age six so I really don't think this
is how our brains perceive time you
really think that it like a day now of
course I think there are better reasons
why time appears to speed up as we get
older so I've come to Venice Beach to
find two groups of people the older and
younger to see if their perceptions of
time differ so what I want to do is I
want to set my timer going and without
counting you tell me when you think a
minute is up let's go start okay
everywhere around the world when this
experiment is performed older people
typically overestimate while younger
people measure it quite accurately all
right probably stop yep whoa one minute
two seconds a minute and two seconds a
minute and five as we get older the rate
at which our neurons fire or our neuron
conduction velocity it decreases and you
can think of this firing rate a little
bit like an internal clock and so if our
internal clock is slowing down that
would make everything else external time
seemed to be speeding up I'm going to
tell you the time
now now one minute that's it that was
one minute one minute minute 17 seconds
not bad right bad I thought I'd be a lot
closer actually I guess I wasn't you
want to know what it really was one
minute 47 way it was almost two minute
it was almost two minutes Arizona it
really is amazing how fast time flies by
it really is our sense of time or chrono
ception is not like one of the standard
five senses it has no specialized
receptor cells and it does not appear to
be localized in just one part of the
brain perhaps this suggests that it's
not one coherent thing at all but it
does seem that our perception of time is
very fundamental studies of rats have
shown that even with their neocortex
removed that is the higher-order
thinking part of their brains they are
still able to learn how to time 40
seconds accurately that's quite
remarkable and it suggests our sense of
time evolved early and is one of the
fundamental functions of the brain but
that doesn't mean our brains always
represent time faithfully for example
have you noticed that really good movies
seem to go by much faster than they
actually are or do you notice that your
vacations fly by there are good reasons
for this when we're focused on something
we don't notice the time is passing and
that makes them feel in the moment
shorter than they actually are at its
best this results in a mental state
called flow this can happen when playing
sports or video games or artists when
they're fully engrossed in their work or
people meditating so I would argue
another reason time speeds up as we age
is because we are more often engrossed
in what we're doing
another thing that appears to make time
speed up is repetition I'm going to show
you a series of images and I want you to
consider how long each one appears on
the screen are you ready go
so which one appeared to last the
longest if you're like most people you'd
probably say the dog but all of those
images actually appeared on screen for
the same length of time the dog seemed
longer because it was novel and
therefore your brain had to invest more
energy in processing it what's
remarkable is that our sense of how long
something is or subjective duration it
correlates highly with how much energy
we're using in our brains now if you
study how much energy people use in
their brains over the course of their
lifetime you find that it Peaks around
age 5 if you think about it this kind of
makes sense because when you're a kid
almost everything is novel to you and
therefore your brain needs to use more
energy for leave 66% of your resting
energy intake that's used by the brain
because of all of the novel experiences
and that must at least in part explain
why time appears to go more slowly so
what can we do to slow time down well
studies have shown that being afraid
increases our perception of time when
arachnophobia this is a real experiment
those arachnophobia n-- saz lasting much
longer than 45 seconds as you'd kind of
expect Plus experiments involving
skydivers or people falling show that
they judge their experience to last much
longer than it actually is another time
when time appears to pass slowly is when
you're bored you know when you're
waiting and waiting that's all you think
about so it seems like time drags
forever since there is so little to
focus on you are acutely aware of just
how much time is passing and so these
boring moments dragged on and on so if
you really want to slow down your
experience of time you could scare
yourself take up extreme sports get into
accidents and intersperse all of that
with periods of boredom but this
viewpoint ignores one important fact
which is that we don't experience time
as just one thing we think about time as
it passes but also as it has passed
before when we remember it and those two
ways of looking at time they don't align
so for example the holidays they feel
like they go by really fast but when you
think back upon
they last a long time that's because you
had a lot of novel experiences and your
brain formed a lot of memories and it
judges the duration of that vacation by
the number of memories that were formed
all that novelty means lots of memories
means it feels like it took a long time
but in a moment it felt fast this is the
paradox the great paradox of our
perception of time if you want time to
go slowly there are a lot of things you
can expose yourself to that will slow
time down but they won't necessarily be
pleasant
so maybe the happiest life and the
longest remembered life is one where
time really seems to fly it's like
Einstein said put your hand on a stove
for a minute and it'll feel like an hour
but sit next to a pretty girl for an
hour and it'll feel like a minute so
what would you like your life to feel
like I want to thank the National
Geographic Channel for sponsoring this
episode of veritasium and if you want to
introduce more novelty into your life
then you should check out their series
brain games the new season begins
February 14th at 9/8 central and this
season they have an episode about all of
your senses including your sense of time
Chronos ception so if you want to find
out more then check out the link to
their website in the description and
thank you for watching
does that feel like that lasted long